the Joe Rogan experience people who are
talking about AI automating programming
have never really written serious code
coding is thinking it's automatic
structure thinking an AI that can
program as well or better than humans is
an AI that just took over the world
that's endgame and that's the end of the
human species and I can give you
arguments but I don't think that's
coming either people who are thinking
and I know I take the opposite side from
some very famous people in this debate
but we're nowhere near close to general
AI not in our lifetimes you don't have
to worry about it even in our lifetimes
really it's so overblown it's it's
another it's a combination of Cassandra
complex you know it's fun to talk about
the end of the world combined with a god
complex like people who have lost
religion so they were looking for
meaning in some kind of end of history
right the reason why I don't think AI is
coming anytime soon is because a lot of
the advances in so-called AI today or
what we call narrow AI they're really a
pattern recognition machine learning to
figure out like what is that object on
the screen or how do you find this
signal and all that noise there is
nothing approaching what we call
creative thinking to actually model
general intelligence you run into all
kinds of problems first we don't know
how the brain works at all number two
we've never even modeled a Paramecium or
an amoeba let alone a human brain number
three there's this assumption that all
of the computation is going at the
cellular level at the neuron level where
nature is very parsimonious it uses
everything else disposal there's a lot
of machinery inside the cell that is
doing calculations that is intelligent
that is an accounted for and the best
estimates are would take 50 years of
Moore's law before we can simulate
what's going on inside a cell near
perfectly and probably a hundred years
before we can build a brain that can
simulate inside the cells so putting it
at saying that I'm just gonna model
neuron is on or off and then use that to
build a human brain is overly simplistic
furthermore I would posit there's no
such thing as general intelligence every
intelligence is contextual within the
context of the environment that it since
we have to evolve an environment around
it so I think a lot of people who are
peddling general AI the burden of proof
is on them I haven't seen anything that
would lead me to indicate we're
approaching general AI instead we're
solving determining
stick close set finite problems using
large amounts of data but it's not sexy
to talk about that if you you're talking
about mirroring the actual abilities of
cells or are you talking about
recreating the actual mechanism like
what what what is going on inside cells
and and biological organism yeah we just
don't know how intelligence works right
we don't know really no idea so most of
the AI approaches basically say we're
gonna try and model how the brain works
when the model at the neuron level which
is saying this neurons on that neurons
often combining their signal but I'm
saying the neuron is a cell inside the
cell there's all this machinery going on
that's operating the neuron that is also
part of the intelligence apparatus you
can't just ignore that and abstract that
out you have to model it down to the
inside the cell level it's also a part
of the biological organism itself exam
and it has all these needs that you know
the biological organism has to have food
and rest and exactly the balance going
on but when you eliminate all that when
there is none of that and it's just
calculations and we get to a point where
it's just this thing that we've created
whether you call it a computer whether
it doesn't have to be a moving thing
even but a thing that you've created
that stores virtually all the
information that's available in the
world stores all of the patterns of all
the thinking of all the great people
that have ever lived all the the writers
all the people that have ever published
anything all the people that have ever
spoken any words stores all of their
points all the counter points all their
contradictions applies logic and reason
and some sort of sense of the future and
starts improving upon these patterns and
then starts acting on its own based on
the information that it's been provided
with where's well first you would have
to actually simulate a structure of the
human brain that can hold all that
information you're basically talk about
tens of thousands of brains worth of
information right
we can't even build one brain in the
next decade or two or three well in
terms of an actual physical brain yes
what about something that recreates the
abilities of a brain like I said nature
is parsimonious so we've got this
three-pound wetware object that can hold
all this data Nature has been very
efficient in evolving kind of how we get
there I I just don't think computers are
anywhere close to that like they can
hold that amount of data with that
complexity with like the holographic
structure of the brain we can recall in
many many different ways and then I
don't think you can evolve a creature to
be intelligent outside of the boundaries
of feedback in a real medium like if you
evolved if you raised a human being a
concrete cell with no input from the
outside they wouldn't have any feedback
from the real world
they weren't evolved properly so I think
just dumping information into into a
thing isn't enough it has to have an
environment to operate in to get
feedback from it needs to have context
but isn't that biological I mean what if
you--if you have just the all the
information that people have accumulated
and the lessons that people have learned
and you program that into the computer
like if if we can take a computer that
can beat someone at chess the the real
question was well can we make some sort
of an artificial intelligence could beat
someone it go
which is far more complex of chess they
figured out how to do that too and that
was a giant shock right these are still
man-made very closed bounded games there
they're not they're not on the road to
the unbounded game of life they are
completely artificial but this didn't go
didn't that give you a little bit of a
pause a little bit go is not go or
League of Legends a fortnight they're
not completely deterministic right but
they're still very artificial very
abouted games being good at go doesn't
mean that you can then suddenly figure
out how to write great poetry right the
creativity for sure is something that's
creativity is the last frontier so I
knew believe that automation over long
enough period of time will replace every
non creative job hmm or every non
creative work but that's great news that
means that all of our basic needs are
taken care of and what remains for us is
to be creative which is really what
every human wants yeah when what are you
doing right now this is a creative job
sure
[Applause]